hey guys it is Friday which means I'm
all set to catch you up on all the
biggest things that happened in gaming
this week unfortunately unlike Mary I
only have a cat who wasn't that keen to
come into work and be on camera so we'll
just have to entertain each other first
up this week EA has announced that yet
another star wars game within the work
even though EA already have five of
their internal Studios working on Star
Wars games they have now also brought on
titanfall develop a respawn
entertainment's to create a third-person
action-adventure based in the Star Wars
universe heading up the team is god of
war 3 director Stig asmussen who has
pledged to pay respect to the sci-fi
franchise and of course to make you a
super fun game but as they have
announced that fallout 4 spa Harbor
expansion will arrive on May nineteenth
for ps4 xbox one and pc the expansion is
set in a post-apocalyptic version of
main bar harbor which has been exposed
to higher levels of radiation you'll
have a mystery to solve new quests to
tackle and nasty of beasties to best the
dlc also includes a bunch of high-level
armor and weapons and more settlements
to explore you can pick ups our Harbor
for 25 bucks or as a part of the
fifty-dollar fallout 4 DLC pass it's no
secret that Blizzard are fans of their
poster girl tracer in overwatch but it
seems she was just a little too good in
heroes of storms just a week after she
was made available for sale in heroes of
the storm Blizzard released a balance
update to tone down traces effectiveness
so you can stop cursing up a storm when
you find yourself up against her
Blizzard have said no other game element
has been touched aside from nerfing
traces health health regen attack damage
and recall ability cool down if you're a
fan of stats you can check out the
specifics of traces adjustments in our
story on gamespot for my last two
stories we must get stuck into all of
this call of duty news beginning with
the announcement of core duty in
warfare infinite warfare will come out
on november four on ps4 xbox one and pc
and as a roommate it will indeed be sent
in space you'll pop into the booth of
captain raise a tier one spec ops pilot
who Helms one of Earth's last remaining
warships and air in space combat will be
a key aspect of the campaign it's also
been confirmed that the campaign will
not feature co-op although the zombies
mode will and for our story of the week
Infinity Ward is producing call of duty
modern warfare remastered the remaster
is set to feature the full modern
warfare campaign and ten multiplayer
maps it will include quote vibrant
current generation visuals with fully
improved texture resolution and detail
high dynamic range lighting lit and
shadowing VFX particles revamped
animation and audio stunning sound and
much more Activision have promised the
included multiplayer maps will be fan
favorites so far we know they include
crush back lot crossfire bog and
overgrown that said the remaster will
only be available in certain special
editions of infinite warfare which begin
at 80 bucks and cannot be purchased
separately let me know down in that
comment box what you cared about this
week and what you think of Call of Duty
infinite warfare this week on site again
spot of Thrones ruminates on the latest
episode the lobby asks where the space
of the right move for call of duty and
we unbox the overwatch collector's
edition that is everything I have you
this week about be sure to have
ourselves an awesome weekend and I will
catch you again on Monday